first time i ever saw you online i was i  was pissed off i was just so [ __ ]  pissed off who the [ __ ] is this [ __ ]  yes they tell me that i'm doing all my  [ __ ] wrong that's right i was so  triggered but i just kept watching your  [ __ ]  you said a lot of things over the years  but i think the biggest thing that hit  me was the fact that you said everyone  has to be kind yes and it's all about  your intention yeah and i just want to  say thank you for that thank you because  i feel like our society these days  everyone's lost the meaning of the word  kindness and you the one who started  spreading that thank you  thank you and brother you know what's  really powerful about your story i'm  willing to be unliked up front to help  the reason i triggered you is because i  put pressure on your [ __ ] and that's  why you were thoughtful you had the  strength inside to know it  subconsciously which is why you stayed